Hello the internet. I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys. I'm
almost giddy with excitement.
Yeah, I can't wait.
We've got a rocket here.
We're here in Indiana,
at Purdue University,
where some very smart students
have made this rocket.
Yeah. It's pretty cool. This is a,
for all you buffens out there,
this is a G motor, G type motor,
and it uses the same solid
fuel as a space shuttle.
Like the solid rocket booster?
Yeah.
On the space shuttle.
Except it's made of bog roll and plywood.
Slight difference.
Slight difference there, yeah.
Also, this is pretty
cool. The bottom part,
the rocket motor, goes from here
to here,
Yeah.
And by the time it gets to here,
it's going 130 miles an hour.
All right. And these things
can break the speed of sound.
So, in like four feet,
it's accelerated to 130 miles an hour?
Yes. Yeah.
And it goes over 1000 feet.
We're gonna need a fast camera for this.
We are, yeah. Let's, yeah.
Let's send it to the moon.
Absolutely.
Well, just shy.
Just shy.
A lot shy.
So, for the close-up,
well shoot on the v2511
at 28.5 thousand frames per second.
Fast.
We're gonna need it.
Very fast.
And we'll get the wide
on the old 4k over there.
Crisp.
So, we need the crisp wide
and the slow tight.
Yeah.
Sweet.
I've got a job as well. This
is what I'm excited about.
You're gonna be carrying
behind something over there.
I'll be filming.
I've got the key of dreams.
Oh, look at that.
And what you do is, very
similar to the space shuttle,
Yeah.
You actually hook it up to a car, right?
NASA do this. They
sacrifice a car every time.
You didn't know that.
No.
True fact.
So, I'm gonna stick it in this
little sort of exciting pad,
and when the right goes off,
I'll push go, and hopefully,
that thing is gonna absolutely
just disappear, yeah.
Five, four, three, two, one.
The cool parachute went out. Oh, sweet.
It's coming down.
I was gonna catch it.
That is coming down in
some way, it's not safe.
Lovely.
It's so much brighter
than our surroundings.
I kind of want to just
do a super dark one.
Oh, right.
So, you can expose the...
Basically, obliterate
all the surroundings.
Yeah.
Just so we can see in
slightly more detail.
I think it'll still blow out white,
but you'll see a little bit more.
So, now we're gonna
get a close-up of that.
It's very bright and very sparky.
So, I'm gonna move the camera in,
and I'm gonna turn the exposure way down.
So, it's essentially going
to be a very dark image
until the rocket ignites
, and then hopefully,
we should see some lovely detail there.
Until the meaty part.
We'll see all the rocket meat.
Very close. Very close.
I'm gonna get even closer.
I can get that and you
in the same frame here.
So, at this point in the video,
we're just gonna repeat the same rocket,
and I was focused on
getting that fast camera
right up in there for
the extreme close-up,
and the wide was kind of
secondary at this point.
We've already got the wide.
It's gonna be the same for this one.
So, I don't have any footage of this,
but I do have my mic audio of
me putting out this question,
Does anyone want to have
a go on the phantom?
And attract the rocket?
Try to give it a go.
So, one of the students volunteered,
and I ran him through the whole thing.
I just said, "Follow the rocket up,
press the red button within four seconds.
Don't bother looking at the screen.
Look at it with your eye,
and just jam the handle down
because it will be that fast."
And there's not really any risk to it.
If the shot doesn't work, that's fine.
We've still got the close-up.
He absolutely nailed it.
And we'll see his shot
in just a little bit.
Okay. You ready?
Yeah.
I think I'm in the
Go-Pro shot here as well.
All right. Okay.
All right. Five, four, three, two, one.
That was it.
I got some of it. Not
all of it. Some of it.
May have just lost a GoPro.
It's not even ours this time.
But by my calculations, that's four GoPros
we've lost.
Another casualty.
Yeah. Another GoPro casualty.
It looks like a much bigger shuttle
because it's taking,
Yeah.
Because it's so slow, it's like,
It's like a really big
one. It's actually just
Yeah.
up at 130 miles an hour.
If it wasn't for the PVC and dictionary,
that would look like a NASA shot.
We could've put a really
accurate model of a person there.
Yeah.
It would look massive.
Look at that. Little bits of
particles coming off.
That is so cool.
See, that's where the
exposure's good here.
Because if I was at the old exposure,
all of that would be white,
on all the madness.
You can see all
the sparks hitting the pad and then...
Yeah. There's actually yellow detail.
That is like music to
yellow. Look at that.
Who'd of thought that a rocket
could be that beautiful.
It's raining sparks.
I love that.
It's nice.
Show our class.
If you nail this, I'll be annoyed.
Oh! Oh! Oh!
No way!
Fair play!
That's awesome.
Have you ever used a phantom before?
You can now retire.
Do you wanna replace Dan?
Okay. So, it got windier,
and we took some weight out
of the top of that last one
because we wanted it to
go faster and further,
but it meant it kept falling over,
so I had to put dictionaries on the floor
in classic Slow Mo Guys style.
Yeah. Don't have any
sandbags or anything useful,
but we do have two dictionaries.
Dictionaries. Yeah, yeah. Slap them down.
But we are at university.
That was awesome. Loved the...
Whoa!
Isn't it scary.
We retrieved the GoPro.
Yes!
It was in a tree.
Well, you say, "we did".
We were filming.
We had nothing to do with it.
We had a very talented team
of GoPro rescuers come and,
Just for that purpose.
Get it out of the tree.
Just in case we lost a GoPro.
It was like 20 feet in the branches, bro.
I thought some of that footage was lovely.
Can you keep that rocket
Sorry.
away from my face?
I'll point it away.
Good.
I'm amazed that they went so high
that I had time to trigger both cameras,
then run to the DSLR, pick it up,
and still see it in the sky.
Yeah. Apart from my job
of pushing the button,
I was trying to find it
because at one point,
it went like 2000 feet, and
all I could see was smoke.
I was like where is it?
I've got no idea. Just...
Well, hopefully, you enjoyed that video.
Special thanks to Purdue University
in Indiana for having us,
and you know, for letting
us launch rockets.
Yeah.
It's class.
That is probably the highest
bog roll has ever got.
All right.
Feel free to follow
us on Twitter as well. Buy
a shirt, and subscribe.
We've got a second channel, too.
Oh, yeah.
Usually, I'm playing pranks on Dan,
who's not so happy about it, but
Yeah.
I have a great time
over there on the second channel.
To make up for that,
I'm going to go and play
with these rockets again.
Yeah?
And you do the camera stuff.
What? Clean up?
Yeah. Just clean by yourself.
Ah.
I'm gonna go
launch some more rockets, okay?
All right.
Yep.